ich glaube es war noch nie in meinem
leben so heißen in deutschland ich war
schon sehr oft in spanien und ich glaube
da war es auch noch nie so heiss wie
jetzt hier leute was geht ab und damit
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
das war das erste mal dass ich zugesagt
habe ja leute ich hoffe euch geht es gut
mir geht es den umständen entsprechend
auch ok ich muss sagen ich habe keine
ahnung ob das wetter überall in
deutschland so warm ist wie hier
der rasen ist sogar auf jeden fall kann
man ist hier gerade genaue mitnehmen das
sonne höchstens zwei minuten aushalten
das reicht jetzt nämlich auch schon
wieder da wo ich wohne sind einfach 35
grad mallorca sind 30 grad wie 29 grad
das geht noch köln 36 grad wollen wir in
köln 37 grad frankfurt 36 grad münchen
28 berlin 32 und hier soll es morgen
einfach 39 grad werden also ich wohne in
der nähe von bielefeld das ist ja
wirklich krank also so 32 grad okay aber
39 und bevor ich schwimmen gehe habe ich
mir gedacht machst du noch ein video
eigentlich habe ich nicht so lust
deswegen habe ich auch ein video
genommen was zum thema passt damit es
ein bisschen spannend wird auch für mich
selber weil man muss sich bei diesem
wetter auch einfach zu irgendwas
motivieren ich könnte auch den ganzen
tag eigentlich im bett liegen und gar
nichts machen hasen die stein heißt ich
habe euch auf instagram gesagt leute
schickt mir einfach mal eure tipps in
der wärme was macht ihr damit euch nicht
so warm ist und ich habe wirklich eine
menge vorschläge bekommen diese ganz
normalen standard tipps wie ja viel
wasser trinken
diese bewirken aber ist im haus bleiben
die berücksichtigen wir nicht dass es
mir zu langweilig es geht nämlich heute
wirklich um die verrücktesten tricks die
werde ich mal ausprobieren alles was sie
mir so zugeschickt habe und ich würde
sagen dafür müssen wir jetzt erst mal
einkaufen deswegen wahrscheinlich sind
sie jetzt auch 95 grad habe ich mir
schon bald das ding war nicht mehr in
der sonne
übrigens auch ein genialer trick im
supermarkt ist es sehr kalt und
eiswürfeln dadurch aber ist red bull
gekauft und die eiswürfel problem ist
nur die werden sicherlich schmelzen
deswegen machen wir jetzt hier mal
selbst kühlung auf höchste stufe wurden
auch ordentlich klimaanlage drauf besser
geht es nicht okay die zurück zuhause
wahlgang schauen uns jetzt einfach mal
für das teure instagram nachricht lang
eine lange hose anziehen wenn es extrem
heiß ist weil dann die wärme in die
beine geht und einem immer warm ist dann
hilft wirklich klaus auch in eine
kühltruhe legen ja vom auch nicht wir
haben ja auch ganz locker kühltruhen
machte beilegen kann das habe ich selber
nie ausprobiert soll dabei helfen kaltes
wasser über die handgelenke laufen
lassen natürlich ganz wichtig dabei das
ganze nicht so lange machen weil sonst
es ist auch nicht so gut für die leute
die keine ahnung haben was das bringen
soll also hier haben wir ja die
pulsadern und tritium menge blut durch
den körper das dadurch endlich das
stellen natürlich gekühlt wird und das
ziel ist es die körpertemperatur ein
bisschen sinken soll dadurch der
kreislauf so ein bisschen angekommen
wird kein paar also irgendwie so wobei
das nicht gerne waffen und muss ich
immer komplett kalt duschen dich du
später nicht gerne so heftigkeit weil
ist wieder einfach zu kalt aber man
stellt das wasser einfach auf full kalt
dann geht man einfach so mit dem ganzen
gewicht runter von zwar suchen
[Musik]
so der nächste tipp bettwäsche im
kühlschrank hat mir meine alte lehrerin
gesagt ich ehrlich sein mir gesagt ich
habe hier auch die rolle darunter damit
es ja damit die sonne hier nicht so ein
ball hat aber ich würde sagen können wir
auf jeden fall mal mit diesem kopfkissen
probieren also doch jetzt heißt es
natürlich ein bisschen abwarten weil das
geht ja nicht so schnell und ich würde
sagen wir kommen zum nächsten kirche
lese einfach mal vor wenn ich lange in
der sonne lag und meine haut
dementsprechend sehr sehr warm ist lege
ich mir mal auf meinen ganzen körper
häfen und warten bis sie geschmolzen
sind
das erfrischt mein körper es tut
natürlich habe ich mir schon mal
eiswürfel so hier reingesteckt oder so
aber so wirklich viele eiswürfel habe
ich auch nicht gemacht weil ich glaube
dass wir ganz schön kalt aber um sie
draußen auszuhalten probiert es einfach
mal
o
ist das gesund wie viele eigentlich
sehen auf den körper wird hier so drei
haben dass man hat mir zu heftig weil du
das ist wirklich angenehm auch hier so
im nacken das ist ganz toll also dass
bis jetzt eigentlich das beste man muss
ja auch nicht übertreiben
das ist aber wirklich sehr vielen sachen
so wenn man zu viel davon nimmt oder zu
viel davon macht dann ist das wieder
schädlich wir kommen zum nächsten trick
paar ist nicht so ein krasser tipper
your nachts immer alle fenster aufmachen
und dann den ganzen tag zu lasten plus
rolland runter und nicht aus dem haus
gehen weil es draußen zu warm ist ja ich
habe nur durch insta und meiner familie
mitbekommen dass es draußen so warm ist
naja ich sitze jetzt schon seit ein paar
tagen 24 7 im kühlhaus also ob das jetzt
wirklich so das richtige ist ich weiß
nicht kaltes red bull und kipper am
körper kacka kacka kacka was mich jetzt
gerade ein bisschen aufregt die sonne
die kommt irgendwie immer weiter
dahinter wir haben jetzt einfach wohl in
gekühlt und eine kippa köttker so fangen
wir natürlich hier mit an
ich war also dem tipp komme ich nicht so
ganz nach aber das hier ist natürlich
gar nicht recht
wobei ja noch eins sagen kann kalte
getränke sollen ja auch nicht das beste
sein einfach weil wenn man sie
konsumiert muss der körper diese kalten
getränk ja auch irgendwie wieder auf die
normale körpertemperatur runterkühlen
das heißt ich glaube die
körpertemperatur liegt so bei 37 grad
getränke die 37 grad warm sind sind am
besten ob das jetzt im keine ahnung ich
bin kein arzt aber das hier ist auf
jeden fall sehr das stelle ich mir auch
wirklich hand for much weil ich jetzt
gar nicht was er mit mind oder hier
babypuder habe ich auch aufgeschrieben
bekommen ich habe im supermarkt in
berlin oder gesucht habe ich aber nicht
gefunden weil es ihr wisst was das genau
ist dann schreibt es mir gerne in die
kommentare
einfach im keller auf den kalten fliesen
boden legen megageil ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen so kalt ist jetzt hier
auch nicht und bequem erst recht nicht
wenn ich jetzt mal so zurückdenke ist
eigentlich das allererste einfach kaltes
wasser ins gesicht also
mit abstand das beste naja ein habe ich
noch eislöffel ins bett und ich würde
sagen das machen wir
naja gut 1 seines wenigsten glaube das
waren jetzt ein bisschen viele jetzt auf
jeden fall das ganze wird voll ich würde
sagen ich freue mich ein paar wieder ein
und steckt dann einige so unter das
kissen und unter die bettdecke
wir haben auch noch das kopfkissen im
kühlschrank wenn mich jetzt hier geben
wir reden hört auch wirklich sehr schlau
das macbook direkt daneben zu platzieren
also man muss ja sagen
das ziel davon wird es sein ich glaube
ich habe jetzt hier ein paar viele
benutzt nur wenn man so jetzt ich weiß
nicht 20 sondern einfach vier eiswürfel
2 in der bettdecke 2 im kopfkissen
verteilt und die über die nacht ein
bisschen schmelzen vielleicht rechnen
auch zwei kann das bestimmt ganz
angenehm sein weil dann hat man immer
einen körperteil an seinem eiswürfel und
man kann es ja auch generell wenn man so
sein bein unter der bettdecke hervor
nimmt dass das recht angenehm ist also
ich muss sagen hier ist jetzt gerade ein
eis hilfe und hier und so jetzt müssen
wir auf jeden fall noch dieses ding hier
raus ziehen
also ich würde das nur sagen wirklich
überraschend echt geil das einzige glaub
ich übrigens ist das war meine
bettwäsche einander die sich als denken
was hast du bitte für eine bettwäsche
das ist meine bettwäsche allerdings von
ganz früher ich habe ja keine
vernünftige mensch wohnt in köln als ist
wirklich extrem kühl gerade das ding ist
ich glaube in zwei minuten ist dass das
nicht mehr ja also es wird eben ganz
schnell waren vielleicht müsste man da
alles mal ins kühlfach ball an für zwei
stunden da keine ahnung also
zusammenfassen würde ich sagen auf jeden
fall alles wirklich ins bett weniger an
helfen einfach das wasser ins gesicht
cars kaltes wasser oder einen bereich zu
bekommen und so machen der rest ist
schwachsinn posten bedanke ich mich für
einige coole insta nachrichten ich hoffe
dieses kurzen spontanen video hat euch
ein bisschen unterhalten
und vielleicht ein bisschen unterstützt
sogar in dieser warmzeit was doch nach
oben da falls ist der fall ist und wir
sehen uns morgen mit einem richtigen
video wieder ich wollte jetzt das
dazwischen schieben einfach weil es so
warm ist haut rein